let's jump to this uh this this first
story right here yeah we got Serge he's
not on the my he's not on the camera so
yeah no camera distance all right let's
uh let's jump to this first story we got
this from The Daily Mail Bud Lights VP
says she wanted to update the fratty and
out of touch branding with inclusivity
days before Dylan Mulvaney's
controversial partnership with beer was
unveiled and uh I'm gonna humble brag
here I called this in my conversation
with Vivek ramaswamy when I said what's
likely happening is these Millennial
women are getting promoted in these
companies they hold these views then
they start adopting these things it is
not it is not like some 56 year old gen
xer or whatever running the company said
this is what we got to do it is a young
Millennial person taking these jobs but
of course what everyone really came here
for is this tweet from DC Drano he says
on March 31st Anheuser-Busch had a
132.38 billion dollar market cap as of
today it is now
128.4 billion you know what that means
the whole the woke Bud Light campaign
has already shaved off nearly 4 billion
in company value don't let Democrats lie
to you conservative boycotts work so uh
white pill moment I suppose boycotts do
work voting with your dollar does work
and this one is the easiest thing for
people to do because everyone's always
like what can I do I don't want to risk
my family I don't know how I can affect
the the electoral system who do I vote
for I can only vote every few years this
one's really easy don't buy Bush don't
buy Anheuser products don't buy
Budweiser don't buy Bud Light and if if
this can be kept up that's the that's
the thing right there right so it's only
worked if it can be kept up
so it's got to be kept up and it's got
it's got to be sustained to a certain
degree where you need one thing to
happen Budweiser apologizes yep that's
it and until the apology don't buy Bud
well yeah right when when they do
apologize I say buy a bunch yeah what
what Market forecasters and everybody
needs to see is that when they did this
campaign with Dylan Mulvaney their their
stock drops their sales drop and then as
soon as they apologized goes right back
up yeah so so it should go up even
higher if they apologize I'll buy a ton
of beer I'm not gonna drink it but you
know but I think the other thing to
think think about is exactly what you
said what can you do
and it's not that you can give money to
cause you like what you can but you can
stop giving your money thing for example
you can stop giving your money to your
alma mater we have a project that was
sponsored called Don't donate where we
ask people the simplest ask in the world
don't donate your alma mater it's not
the same place you're you're pushing
woke ideology you're literally giving it
a kind of financial oxygen same thing
with Bud Light don't buy it any
companies that you've been donating to
or or working with check and see if
they've been bought lately because
there's been a lot of corporate
conglomeration in the last decade right
like Anheuser-Busch merged with some in
Bev yeah yeah and so now there's a bunch
of other brands Anheuser-Busch actually
really really big here's my favorite
Marjorie Taylor green tweeted out a
picture of buying cores and then some
leftist posted Coors woke campaign as
well right but here's my thing I don't I
don't care I do not care if Bud Light
what makes a pride can that's not what I
care about what I care about is Dylan
Mulvaney represents the algorithmic
crisis that is causing teenage
depression that is expanding and
creating wokeness in my view and then
they reward it not only that but Tick
Tock I believe is likely a trojan horse
check that you know the The Story Goes
that in China they get more controlled
and academic content and in the US it's
all weird woke stuff and people who
think they're frogs you know frog frog
self pronouns and stuff like that very
horrible ideas that are corrupting
people's brains and that Dylan Mulvaney
is is a perfect example of what those
algorithms do so when Bud Light dumps
money into that promotes it they're
actually making the algorithmic crisis
substantially worse so my my thing is
like get away from it don't don't fund
that stuff there's a lot of interesting
things at play here because there's also
the ESG score there's also fifth
generational Warfare we could go deep
down the rabbit hole when it comes to
explaining what's really going on here
but on a simple level I think if we
explain what just happened it was a
company trying to sell beer to quote
what they deemed a younger audience but
mainly a part of just preaching to awoke
religion that they were trying to serve
here and it's pretty clear that they
kind of forgot about their customer base
and a lot of people are discussing hey
what what beer should I drink here
what's next beer what's next next beer
should move on I think it's also
important to note here that even woke
people won't be buying uh Bud Light
because it's like you think we're that
simple where you could just put some
person on there and that's going to make
me want to buy your your fluoride filled
pitch drink no thank you I don't want
that bull crap anywhere near me it's an
endocrine disruptor and I think a lot of
people with the discussion that I would
love to have here to have a deeper
discussion maybe instead of replacing
your beer maybe maybe maybe let's let's
let's stay away from the move creating
endocrine disruptors that do of course
have a very negative effect on you and I
think this is a perfect time to start
that conversation being like hey don't
support this bull crap because it's bad
for you I don't drink yeah and how evil
do you have to be because the video of
this VP came out and she's talking about
we have to appeal to a younger younger
audience he has the rainbows behind her
what kind of evil person do you have to
be to say we're going to get young kids
hooked on beer and alcohol you are a low
vibrational like bad human being when
you're such a corporatist where you're
like we got to get all these people
hooked on alcohol
that's what she said peppered with woke
language throughout and so here's the
thing they're targeting college kids
they're targeting people who are under
the legal age to drink now and that
being said I think 18 should be the
legal drinking age I think it's
ridiculous they raised it to 21 in the
first place and I actually think beer is
actually pretty great
um I don't drink it the problem is abuse
not having some I might have a beer once
or twice a year to be completely honest
depending on the situation but it's not
going to be Bud Light because Bud
light's just it's like not really beer
it's kind of Castle
there was even a news there was even a
new medical study that came out showing
that even moderate drinking has very
negative cognitive effects for your
brain and ages your brain and stops
blood flow to your brain there the move
things is real there's there's a reason
Bill Gates has moops okay and it's not
accidental it's not a coincidence you're
saying he drinks too much beer oh that
and of course all the horrible
pesticides and byproducts there's also a
lot of glycopate in of course the beer
as well it's good to be back to get this
off of my chest here
to finally be able to explain a lot of
this stuff because you know at the end
of the day here it is a corporation
trying to sell a product a product that
does have a lot of negative consequences
for people that should be the discussion
I think so let me ask you this question
I I maybe we can all agree I think
everybody would be better off if they
just drank water
you know that we actually do have
glasses over there sorry I didn't find
them so I'm using a measuring that's why
I like it hey it holds water that's good
now here's here's an important thing to
consider too for for this stuff the
reason why I really really am energized
in enervated by the story is Bud Light
deserves to lose money not just because
we disagree with the ideological
position of say you know Tick Tock Dylan
Mulvaney or whatever
Bud Light deserves to lose money because
this has to be one of the stupidest
business decisions
irrespective of wokeness in that
you've got people from the ages of 21 to
on average
79.3 years old
your your market share is 50 plus years
57 58 years and what they've done is
said we've got to get rid of the Frat
culture and appeal to a younger audience
so they're targeting people from the
ages of 21 to 25 in an effort to sell
beer at the expense of 25 to 80. and
they've got to understand the amount of
financial duress people are under that
are from the age of 21 to 25. young
people it's a constant theme on this
show and others that people don't have
money they don't have Direction the
school is too expensive they're in debt
like well they do have money but hold on
the money's being valued the money's
being devalued but but real quick and
that actually makes them smart but
they're targeting a segment of
population that doesn't have money
that's the weird thing that's actually a
good point you know it's funny because
they say when times are good people
drink when times are bad people drink
more and so right and so maybe they're
hoping like maybe the real Gambit here
is these young people are depressed and
listless they're gonna get drunk do you
think what better way to forget your
Sorrows what better way to live in your
pod and eat the bugs and of course if
you remember during covid the alcohol
industry skyrocketed that they were
allowed to have liquor stores that were
allowed to be open meanwhile the mama
pop stores weren't allowed to be open as
well so a lot of people drank a lot a
lot of people who are depressed drink a
lot and it makes a lot of emotional
issues a lot of emotional problems that
much worse for a lot of individuals so
when you're going after a key
demographic that still has a part of
their brain developing and you're saying
let's put booze in there come on let's
call let's call it out for what it is
here to me a lot of this is just
absolutely disingenuous I don't care I I
think there was just someone at Bud
Light saying we just need to make money
let's just let's just make as much money
as we can we don't care how we're going
to do it and then and then and then they
bring in the woke religion as a part to
be subservient see I was talking to
Vivek Rama Swami last week and this is
the where the conversation was going and
I I said I disagree what I think we're
seeing at these companies
they hire a 24 year old woman 10 years
ago she is a she's a marketing intern
two years later she's full-time staff
now she's uh you know a marketing
producer or something like that it's now
been a decade she fought her her boss 56
goes what's her name do you know her
name Luke
so so here's how I'm imagining he goes
Alyssa it's about time I retired I'm
about 60 some odd years let's say you
say I said he's in his 60s and he's like
I think this is a job you can handle and
she's like thank you so much and then as
soon as you walk outside she goes let's
sponsor Dylan Mulvaney and that's what
happened it there was there like there
are these people on the left that are
saying they did all this market research
they know exactly what they're doing I'm
like no no they don't yeah the people
who are woke who are ideologically
driven are not thinking logically about
numbers yeah they're thinking we are now
wearing the institution like a skin suit
let's Advance our cause I'm
automatically thinking of that Vice news
skit where they were taking
um adult
um toy employees and throwing them at
the wall randomly that could be it too
you never know this woman clearly is
woke though we saw yeah this video where
she's pronouns in her bio she's
peppering her language and I think that
the key thing is what you said Tim it's
that these people have intentionally
trained themselves not to think that all
of their information comes through a
funnel to promote wokeness but I guess
what I was thinking about have you heard
the the expression there's no such thing
as bad press yeah yeah this seems to
belie that there is bad press and bad
press can harm I think the phrase
there's another thing is bad press
typically applies to an individual right
I think someone like Ben Shapiro has
actually greatly benefited from Bad
press but to be fair there's a
double-edged sword that comes along with
it in that
the bad press for an individual and for
a commentator they become more prominent
for someone like Ben Shapiro or for
anyone any of us here is that the more
they talk about you the more you become
the subject and the figure to be talked
about if you are Anheuser-Busch you are
on top of the mountain there's nowhere
else to go the only the only press
they're going to get is going to be
negative for their stock so bad press
bad for your stock individuals we don't
have stock so the more attention we get
the more we can capitalize on it for Bud
Light we'll put it I'll put it this way
they've got an opportunity when they
bring politics into beer which seems to
make no sense in my opinion for the most
part but when they this opportunity is
can we capture a large portion of one
demographic well my attitude is how
about you don't do any of it and you try
and just capture as much of the entirety
of people who drink beer by being a
neutral beer company as soon as they
enter the political Fray they segment
off a large portion of Their audience if
you are a political commentator or a
celebrity you're not gonna get a market
cap that is the entire population of the
planet
now imagine a company like Coca-Cola
Coca-Cola's market cap literally is
every human on earth except for maybe
like North Sentinel Island where they've
never made contact with people or
something like that so they have no
incentive whatsoever to be divisive and
bad press is bad if your market cap is
everyone
Coke Bud Light whoever else they want
everyone on the planet drinking their
product well go to war with one half of
them and you'll only lose customers if
you're a commentator and you're a
celebrity so who cares if 80 of the
world hates you 20 likes you and you'll
make money off them so bad bad all
around for Bud Light use it for us
something Peter I think you were
alluding that she they didn't seem to
know what they were doing is that what
you said earlier yeah what I think is
happening is that these folks and and
Alyssa has pronouns in her bio and she
Peppers all of her legs and I would
encourage people to watch those videos
where she's explaining why she did this
they're not capable of independent
rational thought they're they're they
view themselves as white Knights who
promote the ideology this is a way to
promote her moral values and and within
that then she convinces herself that
well it would increase market share will
increase sales but it's just not true I
think it's the word inclusivity do we
have that video of Alyssa oh that video
is wonderful it's so great
it's incredible that she donated herself
like that but I guess everyone knew who
she was on the team anyway and the way
she says we need to we're looking to do
Inc I think it's the word inclusivity
inclusivity yeah something something
something and an inclusive something
something and you're like why did she
use the word inclusivity twice she
doesn't know what it means that's why
well that video that you mentioned was
from March 30th and ever since I haven't
seen much kind of
um any kind of words from Bud Light
afterwards after this oh that's from
okay yeah so that's from an earlier
video where she was explaining what she
was yeah and I wanna I wanna underscore
something Tim said that if you really
want to show that you can change and
make a difference it has to be sustained
able like you have to literally
continue to not buy the product until
they apologize and if you don't do that
then you're actually working against
your interest because companies are
going to keep doing this I don't think
an apology is enough they'll just issue
some crap they don't believe and then
try and the apologies everything the
apology is everything
because it's a signal it's a costly
signal it's a it means they will if they
issue an apology that means
Anheuser-Busch said the the risk to our
business from the far left cult is less
than the risk to our business from
pissing I see so you're not trying
that's a good point you're not trying to
destroy the company you're trying to
change the direction the company takes
yeah and we're not going to be held
hostage to to woke Maniacs we're just
not going to be held hostage to these
people thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time